you also now are doing something on big
boy's neighborhood the head talks
yeah that's gonna get me into some [ __ ]
for people who don't know you kind of
originally
started at iheart helping like being a
part of big boy's show now that was
essentially
doing you're answering calls yeah yeah
that's that's another thing i've never
talked about that
the when i when when they when i got
hired at iheart they hired me for two
hours a week
right eventually uh something a position
opened up for me
to basically answer the phones and
screen calls for big boy i did that for
three years
and that's the thing that's what nobody
talks about it's about doing those types
of things it's like
whatever you bring value that's number
two in my thing bring value
yeah be undeniable and then bring value
that's number two whatever room you in
hey pick up a mop you know i'm saying go
get the door you know what i'm saying go
get put some waters in the refrigerator
whatever you got to do to bring value to
the situation that's what i did
with big boy and i appreciate that
opportunity i felt like
me running boards and editing audio and
[ __ ] behind the scenes on big boy
allowed me
to get a paid education and how to
produce radio on the highest level
it was almost like you know a lot of
people might be like man [ __ ] this i'm
that's how i feel i really pay but now
but like yo you're getting the real
that's how i felt at first if i'm being
100 honest when i first
first told me about what i would be
doing i was like man i want to be on the
air though
i'm a radio [ __ ] right but silas
was like
get in the room right what you get in
the room is over get in the room and
bring value
stop worrying about what you're called
when you're in the room and i'll use
that for saying
that same ideology even to this day like
even with women it's like don't worry
about
what we are just be do the job that you
want before you get the title
which is why you're single west coast